right so emergency evacuation by
following good wife should be given it's
not a meeting so clearly we put that
through please note this meeting with
the audio recorded should we be required
to evacuate building will you please
leave and run by the drawer next to the
forest type CX please hold both
handrails in case the stairs a little
slippery if anyone is an able to use
instead but they please allow others to
exit the room before they go to the
virus vector or collecting them be given
assistance now 75 will be in the public
car park in the side of the Civic sweet
Vietnam delayer evacuation collecting
declines and please do not return to the
building until given permission to do so
by cancerous top notch right poses
Francis opposition web steps are there
any others i don't think there are right
minutes of the meeting on me take the
tune is either which my sinuses are to
record
okay any declarations of interest if
anything should arrive soon the meeting
things to let us know of anyone make
sure it's recorded massively third so
the executive reports Malik matey's
there are none so next I'm going to be
the evening in turn finance strategy if
you die 16 so get straight to that
some digitally no this is an extreme out
yeah I'm buddy
the [ __ ] entire up to the financial
scratch strategy is no it is something
that that's an ever-evolving document
changes from time to time balaton plan
we've been in a position where the
strategy has has changed over recent
years to match the changing
circumstances in which we progress out
the essential brand being in reduce
steadily the impact of new homes
bourbonnais Cheryl's austerity the
redesign that we face them and so on so
it is important that we keep this
document as as active as we can and if
I'm totally honest our suspect impasse
Queens we've often accepted what
officers have said to us as it has a
document that it's necessary and there
no but we know that has changed coming
up in the future so it's really
important that we really start to get
our heads around the impact and the
potential impact of future changes so
the MTF s is becoming more important for
where we go into the future and
potentially there's an all-out election
next year so whatever party gets any
actually going to be there for a short
while so given that there's a little
administration possibly coming up there
needs to be stability and where the
counts is taking its up it's not
straightforward understanding all the
different aspects and even though I've
been probably holder for a short while
now I'm quite happy to admit from time
to time I see things that do take a to
form a double lock and a good deal of
understanding but I don't make decisions
we make decisions as an executive so
what we'd like to do today
usually like love to do today is take
you through a little bit more of the
detail within this the email that you've
got it is not to be taught through it
it's some supporting document it's a
supportive document to help understand
these strategies are on out on over to
yoga yeah I think how much done jam
there but as long as it takes all your
right so here's my first to have you
meaning so thanks for having me
and plays my name they actually you can
greatly project meeting starting off
basically their financial effect in the
envelope of the current of last year
that has gone I as to how bien what any
issues that came up in the last year and
then we are to look at the budgeting
process for 16 17 and then you have to
look at the long-term financial accounts
the medium defiance of strategy did
anything that come on that we have liked
it and to take you to that obviously we
also touch touch on this document on the
damn funny are we just have enough
thousand tags what are our options
already know eight having stated on
there on the document and the most
important part of this document is the
HCT is he just to tribute anyway I've
got a couple of scenarios being there
you take the proportion of time i would
say quickly go to the financial updates
and then spend a bit more time density
is because that's a little bit more
complex
question flask and of course equal to
the mtns as well so are the sounds to
gain getting so on the financial updates
recently consulate of be concerned about
the rivals basically the right our
process is actually pretty much
mechanical force incentive offers
various stages where when it is over
deep for example you might kind of a
situation where the company and the
liquidation usual business range 500 APD
the individual and declared bankruptcy
or it may be a situation where
the plan in place yet so I'm giving you
the three types of
in main categories on the on me on the
email that Simon forwarded you
folding and then just to give you an
idea quite a few times and results we
have our bankruptcy liquidation on
economy to pursue data data has
absconded page of the dead have been
there for a long time puddin finally
feel recovering it our situation where
people have died and all about
broker or tiara mainly on the house and
inside and then you have got the limited
airport I was like my dog is a very
whew No
so in any question specific questions
you have I found out to place into
it's not really question Joseph yeah
it's just the concern I wasn't aware of
those wrong I was then known as door I
don't have a form of the writers as
though anyone so here and we do nothing
about that but I think Wilson it's to
mention the amount of good workers
government in that
they are actually bringing in today sure
so it didn't all of that but in future
it'd just be nice if I could just have
to because the phone call or an email
just to explain why here i mean when i
read that before i was like oh and who
was that come from you know it was and i
had a few phone calls from ikea malm bed
w it looks ago that that part of the
report have been far too narrow for
break down to spanish in there but at a
time it has been never shop right a job
yeah fine in fact the business range has
become day because early the business
they didn't have any mishap on right on
we will be collected the debt collector
the money and give it back
subscribe to the phenomena gave it back
to us now it's an issue recently
valuation by the
it actually could have a risk in the
same
it's not right detection to the
valuation changes and we might lose
advertiser as a whole including about
for ourselves preceptors to the tune of
300 9,000 pounds low in terms of
collection the impact for our see the
bart went out so i think you should see
the allow button if a few of those typos
write-offs at our values and change
counting we will be having a series list
one of the other things that i mentioned
so from time to time it's not just a
one-way street we occasionally are able
to drive back sums of money once it's
risen up it's not completely closed then
the incursion example of that yeah the
when detectives Linden off it is not
normally data the data another it's not
at all we are to be a bit out of date so
I thought of the debtor is concerned
energy still over to the counts or the
presenter so we will take every step
necessary to person obviously here the
resource implications of action
we have an agreement with accounting and
the other preceptors on a different
which is actually to share the spoils in
a way if you collect more income the
conjugates the shared plan Chara feet
under one contact so divisive so the
agreement is actually need to our Frost
jinxiu based let me get a shower so yeah
sure i'll be obviously a lot of this
stuff i think the council's we already
know yeah i know you you going through
it a little bit chapter and videos but
this motivation came out for a reason
kazeem is all the reasons as to why
perhaps some things were known to some
of the council's if you like that some
things are going through and that's what
we're really looking forward it's too
not so much why we know that you have
bankruptcies notification etcetera we
understand there may be debts
outstanding that not so much if you like
that you know is what you know
calgary methods that can come through
money does come through occasionally so
I think it's really just understanding
how you know these figures were right
there yes so you know i'ma cut too short
but you know it's almost turning this
into a training session I don't know
which you shouldn't really be sure okay
sorry did you want say so yes thank you
for watch Jerry yeah there was something
that it was mentioned earlier on by
cancer Smith in regards to you know
there are certain differences that have
happened in the past and there are
changes now are we looking at a
different emphasis I will get a more
pessimistic emphasis in production of
these feathers and would it be want to
sign up maybe an hour previous leaders
work
to the sapient ok and at least yeah
basically these are historical setting
these are the past their sell-by date
services not something actually near
forecasting allgemeine produce something
or other he's an event has taken place
the debt is over to us and the air for
it try to recover I'm not talking about
with that thing think it's very lovely
previous previous years because we can't
argue but we have weekly future figures
think things are things are changing and
we've got some user I think it in
perhaps might be were just looking a
little bit more closely a potential
funding for the capital program because
that that's going to have biggest impact
as into the future take the last he's
getting character that can forgive me
about them we could sit here all night
yeah
and analyze the ins and outs at this
particular is what we do anyway isn't it
is but running the council if we look at
the decisions that are required of us
the ceiling and if we could possibly
keep to those please and if any member
certainly the executive has any
questions which are not part of those
particular recommendations and therefore
decisions can we do it another time
privately or indeed collectively is that
all right and I think I mean the point
is we pass the stick to the agenda of
the meeting these are the two dinner
we've got certain decisions and we got
reasons for the decisions and it's
really just to find the whole idea of
bringing four times to clarify while in
silence is where we six
and things that we've got to look for in
the future actually like because these
are some good things there were some bad
things that are coming forward and we
all know that but and I think that's
gonna talk about if you like in another
place we have more time and more
information etc and it's like you throw
this sort of thatís tonight a little bit
we're very 4 sep many tribes and start
that is mazing alright as a bit half so
are there any questions into I mean
jokes here now and we've got the book
pro your whole it does anybody want ask
any particular questions re khuda ke
she's obviously one I think you've
covered that's there anything else
anybody get in here chairman if I if I
come against affect the decision 1.1
recommendation is to note the empty
office okay can we at least do that we
let everyone know TC the next one is the
outline timetables and one got a problem
with that I think you can say well there
might be one to the one thing that we
would like to today is to bring forward
from the consultation targus a bit dizzy
from without that's quite a period of
time and can be limiting after their
time civilized had that image back
pocket before we start okay mind if
roulette and decorate members really
what I go through them yeah yeah the
range of public consultation he's
obviously that one funny looking at
exporting remains unchanged I think
there was any appetite to changing as
such which there may be happened is that
yeah the options aren't a naughty the
pages because I am we'll get our text
about that we really need to speak on
that sorry for not changing anything
about you need to speak to me Thank You
chairman Rogers and said exactly that
because it's not cheating paying for the
three yeah it's not what we're talking
to is it's not in the agenda
so is my car assorted I've really
mentioned that's not yep it's not really
part of the ginger chairman if I because
I like to have time to consider what is
presented to me verbally I personally
don't absorb it quite as well as if I
had time to read it that I much prefer
we've got a doc come up there I don't
how many pages that document you through
43 al jolly good which we had seven
minutes of nap now so don't need to go
to the audit yes yep excuse me if I cut
a document I'm going to go through a
hundred as other officers will tell you
every comma and every full stop I'm not
going to be guided which pic to read by
by anyone I'll read the whole life is
presented to me at seven minutes is not
adequate search please if we can
postpone that your recommendation as i
understand it it is the status quo so if
that's your recommendation unless any
other member as an alternative proposal
i'll certainly move acceptance of that
recommendation
what is necessary a sensitive bowl
second yeah thank you agree they're
hungry thank you right so as far as
that's concerned I appreciate you know
going to be traveling documents is you
know i'll be in the doctor who has the
best problem that we have here neh team
ideas like brought into the 2 16 17
budget I think including members are
always bringing ideas forward I went
away our weekly certainly got some
things and Nick he's not here today yeah
so said it was some good ideas coming
forward for that and I think you know we
need to discuss those into the future so
and you know that's something I think we
need to agree and that's a constant
process so members you believe that okay
so I think we've gone through that
particular one
movie on
and
but to item 7 is progress on decision
I'm not I need to go through every page
of this just ultimately to raise any
mail items yes please page 18 so Tory
you never the answer some time to
process happens arias
to safety of its indications being
waiting and I think that should be the
stakes their data sharing protocol has
been free well it has been lonely it's
and scientists and it's still with this
place and following my nerve endings for
a little teen
stop with the place and when it's time
then vetting process will begin
take up to three months okay okay you've
got delegate authority to do with this
anyway it's just a concerned it says
GREENman yeah [ __ ] right so if it
actually out of trying now minutes
coming out of the time is it I'm not
showing its stuff
that's usually the indication for
operating our enemies but as I so happy
to take your advice on that there was a
great yeah okay are there any other
items please anybody wish to raising the
item set of you it's lesia Thank You
general yes I guess it's just another
17.3 we're both a little town at sector
plans the items in red important that as
far as raleys and so which I've leave
the last one come through we biking from
the inspector to come back on that this
month we hope
we hope to have that going forward i
believe sep tember for you handsome
adoption but that's saved by miles 2014
so obviously is at this time yeah as far
as a success Ontario time at that time
today you're waiting on the inspector
that one
anybody absolutely members except item
set of them item 8 is the exclusion
resolution so I'm sorry but to lose you
there members of the public would come
to the end of the business so you can
delay with your presence remain report
contained exact information or their
personality and my